number three alexandria cortez is
putting her foot down once and for all
uh so you better listen up because she
is
serious this time here she is listen
what we saw last week was not just
a violent coup attempt um
but we als also saw a dereliction of
duty
and a betrayal of our country and a
betrayal
of the oath that we swear and that
is why i have demanded the resignations
of senators ted cruz
senators josh hawley
majority leader republican majority or
rather republican minority leader
in the house mccarthy kevin mccarthy
yeah and you know and i will counter
that by saying i demand the resignations
of
alexandria cortes
joe biden camille harris
mark zuckerberg
colonel sanders i just i demand
everyone's resignation
um yeah this is we can make jokes about
it of course it's just this this
impotent
i i demand the resignations of i demand
the resignations of of
all the republicans in congress i demand
it
i want your resignations on my desk
tonight
so we can laugh at the impotence of that
but but really this is just another
example of
you you look at how the left has reacted
to uh one example of
right-wingers writing okay we've had
we had precisely one example of that
period in memory and this is how they
react to it
you know they're they're shutting
everything down demanding resignations
of everybody
donald trump has kicked off twitter they
impeached him
you know just a uh wiping out without
millions of conservative accounts
they've they've occupied
dc with the military this is how they
react to one
on the left now compare that to how the
right reacted
to months and months and months of left
wing writing nothing
they can do anything and they had the
power to do things
they were in a position of power they
did absolutely nothing
so if you want to understand the
difference between the left and right
between really democrats and republicans
that's it right there one example of
right wingers rioting
um a small by the way a small percentage
of the people that were at the rally
engaging in this behavior and what the
democrats do they just shut
everything down occupy the city impeach
everything
right they go absolutely nuclear
response to it and on republicans
very very tolerant and patient you know
if you're on the left you can just riot
ride all you want we don't want overstep
bounds we don't want to do anything
you know donald trump in fairness he did
he did tweet law and order in all caps
he
he tweeted that many times
and conservatives made excuses for that
they said what else do you expect him to
do he's only the president
he can't do anything else so he's you
know he's just trying to respect be
respectful and
what do you think what do you let me ask
you what do you think joe biden is going
to do
if this becomes a semi trend of
of of small pockets of uh you know trump
supporters or
people that at least could be uh at
least they can claim our trump
trump supporters rioting or engaging
this kind of baby if this becomes even a
semi trend we don't even have to talk
about hundreds of riots like we had on
the left
if there are even just a few of them
through the first
few months of of biden's tenure how do
you think biden's going to react to that
or at least how do you think the biden
administration is going to react to that
i mean they will be occupying cities
they're going to move the military in
they're going to come down with an irfs
they're already doing it
because they can and why why would they
react that way because they
can because they have the power to do it
and so they will
when republicans have the power to do it
they just don't
and they make excuses for it and then
when they no longer have the power to do
anything
that's when they pretend that if they
only did have the power again
this time they would do something well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content